house representatives just passed a
defense bill excuse me that will cost
more than 770 billion dollars we told
you about it previous nights this week
some of it is hard to defend but some of
it is worthwhile and some of it is
interesting
so the bill includes a provision to
create a permanent office under the
defense secretary that will be tasked
with investigating reports of ufos that
office would quote carry out on a
department-wide basis the mission
currently performed by the unidentified
aerial phenomenon task force
interesting it's unclear if the senate
will approve that provision we'll be
watching lu elizondo led the pentagon's
secret ufo task force for years he joins
us tonight to assess so thanks so much
for coming on so
what would this do if it becomes law and
do we need it
yeah tucker this this is really historic
yes first of all we absolutely need it
it's it's a long time coming frankly we
should have had it decades ago if you
ask me uh but it's it is historic and
it's historic for several reasons um in
this obscure five pages that most people
may not be aware of it really says a lot
in fact it it first of all it creates an
environment where it disestablishes the
uap task force which was a temporary
capability to begin with and solidify as
a permanent capability
two it also forces the secretary defense
to report on an annual basis to congress
what we've learned about uaps three it
also requires us to now work with our
international friends and allies
that's a big deal and if that wasn't a
big deal enough
two other items that i found very
interesting uh number four is that it uh
and you kind of broke this story a few
years ago it requires any recovered
material associated with uaps to finally
be reported to congress and then last
but not least it also requires uh the
government to report to congress any
adverse medical effects that are that
have been encountered by our our pilots
who may have come up close and personal
to these uaps
so that suggests there have been adverse
medical effects that american servicemen
have been hurt by
proximity to these to these objects
yeah it actually suggests two things it
suggests that what you just said that
pilots may have have actually suffered
medical consequences adversely but also
that there is recovered material uh and
that recovered material may be in the
possession of the us government so does
anybody that you're aware of from the
pentagon believe sincerely believe that
these objects are part of the russian or
chinese military or that they're they're
foreign military
aircraft
i mean
honestly if you were to ask them off the
record no i think the consensus is that
this isn't russian or chinese technology
of course you still have to keep that
door open just to crack
and i think it helps have the
conversation help socialize it initially
to especially some folks who are just
now actually hearing about this for the
very first time as as crazy as it sounds
there are still people when you say hey
have you heard about the uap issue that
we're encountering off the coast of
california or over in the middle east
they're saying no what are you talking
about so
unfortunately you still have to keep
that part of the conversation open but i
think the general consensus that we're
dealing with something else
yeah something else i mean why is this
not the biggest story ever of our
lifetimes and of course it is lou
alexander thank you so much for all your
efforts on this always my pleasure hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else